[Musique]
igor et grichka la question c'est est-ce
qu ici on a parmi nous mais oui
franchement les extras dans la vie de
tous les jours des femmes et c'est
maintenant
non mais franchement oui vous êtes
sérieux l'ont pas sérieux il y en a rêvé
de la partie oui alors ils savent pas il
ya des extra terrestres parmi nous merci
que j ai franchement mais il me faut il
les adore benouza président qu'est ce
qu'il ya écrit j'ai dit il
[Applaudissements]
on l'a perdue vézina ont attendu un
moment j'adore et vous faites très bien
les actions du sud ou à temps et que ça
peut te [ __ ] des rentrées et toi tu as
mangé mon père me parlait d'une avance
somme avec l'accent du sud
i-gr alesi de time machine qui fait des
patates et moi donc c'est quoi des
bouchons dans les oreilles et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
l'émission n'est pas normal koné
démission par le big bang s'il allait
couteau pas bien colas adéquat il roula
jamais vu comme un slogan il est venu il
n'a pas su starter délire mais
j'adorerais
je voulais vous fait quel accent vous
allez y on essaie de trouver le coin
c'est mon frangin
labannère dans un degré qui tourne bien
en ce moment ils sont dix parlez-nous
d'un objet comme ça avec l'accent du sud
un dernier un dernier pour la route pour
motif sérieux
ouais mais ça sérieux elle connaît déjà
les traînées bagnole je te raconte le
truc d'une vraie âme damnée moniot
l'étude en salle 6 2 et de vous dire de
place oubliez les gens qui nous redonne
la malaxe ont donc la banale qu'est-ce
qui se passe
et au lieu de tombola comment un premier
la première le volet et salah et plonge
de seconde la presse et nous souvenions
pour moi c'est des méchants
et chris kaman d'ailleurs qui joue avec
où le livre des merveilles
technologiques sur la vie des gosses